[Music]
so welcome everyone
and in my talk i will discuss some
aspects of of shiny open source but
before we move on
let me briefly remind you why our
community praises
shinee so much so first of all
you can prototype your applications like
very fast so you can create your first
poc in a matter of like hours
rather than days that all comes
wrapped in a neat user interface powered
by bootstrap so you don't really need to
reinvent the wheel when it comes to
styling obviously you can customize it
as it was shown in the previous
presentations
shiny leverages the power of r when when
it comes to the data analysis so
in the back end you can use those
powerful packages from the thai diverse
family for instance
and shiny also it's nicely integrated
with a large number of visualization
packages like ggplot leaflet
data table and even more interactivity
so how different ui components talk to
each other is quite easy to understand
but with all those advantages in mind
sometimes i have impression that we
forget that the true power of shiny lies
in the fact that this is fully open
source software
and i came to realize that recently when
i was like
reading again through the a blog post
describing the
the winning solutions to the second
annual shiny contest and i realized for
how many different applications you can
actually use shiny
so here we have an interactive data
storytelling we have a machine learning
backed application
for visualizing your musical taste we
have
data analysis dashboard that presents
the most popular github repositories and
finally you can even make games as
proven by our very own pedro
but all of that wouldn't be really
possible without all of those like shiny
extensions that are available now
and every year there's even more and
more of them
so there is no way that i could cover
all of them in details
during my 10-minute slot but i decided
to cherry-pick just a few
without which i can't even start
thinking
about about starting developing my own
shiny applications
so let's kick off with shiny js
which is uh which is a package from dean
atali
that lets you perform common useful
javascript operations in shiny like
hiding elements disabling inputs
resetting
values or alerting some variables that i
often use for debugging myself the cool
thing
though is that you don't really need to
know any javascript to start using
that because everything is wrapped in
our functions that are nicely documented
so it's quite easy to get started
then we have shiny widgets which
is basically a collection of extra
components to enhance your shiny
applications
the repository contains a big selection
of the components that are usually
nicely documented with little code
snippets
such that you can copy and paste the
code and and adjust it for your own
needs
some of my favorite elements are for
example ticker input
those fancy checkbox button or
horizontal multiple choice selector
then we have small but rather powerful
package
shiny css loaders that helps you with
adding a loading animations to the
output instead of bringing
them out so i mentioned you already that
shiny uses this power of r for daily
data analysis
but but certain actions can take a while
so it's better to provide our user
with some feedback that there's
something happening in the background
so you can do it with simple one
function call
with spinner that that adds to your
shiny those like little animations
okay and i wouldn't be myself if i
haven't mentioned
about some packages that help you style
your apps as
in epsilon we care a lot about how the
apps look
so starting from the left we have vs4
dash
that provides you with bootstrap for
a admin lte skin for your dashboards
then we have shiny mobile mobile the
help that helps you create
mobile ready shiny apps that look almost
like native apps for ios and android
and then on the right we have our own
shiny semantic
that helps you to attach an alternative
look to your
shiny applications okay and i mentioned
that i just scratched the surface here
so there is even more fantastic shiny
extensions that you can find on this
shiny awesome repository that i
discovered recently
and and this uh this
little repository summarizes and
categorizes uh various
shiny extensions such that you can
always find something
that you that you need there i encourage
you to check it out
okay but using all those shiny
extensions is just like one way how you
can take advantage of shiny
open sourceness but you can help
yourself
with with building those tools
so first of all you can start from
something
as simple as reporting a bug or or
bringing some like new idea to the table
by creating
a new new issue on github repository
or emailing an author of the code but
remember to be respectful with that
as very often open source code is
created by enthusiasts or as in
our case this is something that we do
outside of our daily work with client
then if you feel comfortable enough
actually to
to fix some bug or or
contribute with with new idea to certain
package
feel free to do some coding and create a
new pull request
but remember first about reading and
contributing guidelines
as they usually contain a useful
information
with what to do or not to do on a given
repository
remember about testing all of your
changes so
that you see that you didn't break all
the like previous functionalities of the
code
and always ask politely for a review and
it's good to have another pair of eyes
to
see to check the quality of your code
okay but now if you still
see that there is some uh that there is
no
solution to your problem available then
you can move on and
think about creating your own package
and remember that for starters
it doesn't really need to be perfect
some solution
is better than no solution whatsoever
and and always you may find someone
in the community who would be interested
in collaborating and moving the project
forward if you don't really have time to
do all the coding on your own
and then a couple of tips from from me
remember about adding tests to your
package from the early beginning as it
will
really spare you so much troubles at the
later stage of the development
remember about the documenting your code
for you it might be quite obvious how to
use your own
functions but not necessarily for the
users of your package
and recently it became a good practice
to add
interactive examples to to to your
repository
such that users can test what this like
package actually
can help them with before they even
download it
and then comes the fun part so remember
about publishing it sharing with others
to get
credits and accomplishments it's it's
really satisfying feeling
okay with that let me mention our very
own epsilon open source family
related to shiny so you have a variety
of packages here related to styling
packages that help you with debugging
translations and and routing
i will not go into too much details here
as we as we have
a separate pre-recorded video available
where i discuss some of the
possibilities of those packages and a
little bit more details
just let me mention here that every year
we try
to extend this list so stay tuned as
later on philip and marek will tell you
a little bit more about
our two new projects okay
so to to sort of like prove you that
that
our packages can be useful a couple of
months ago we decided to challenge
ourselves and and try to implement a
fully functional
shiny applications in less than 24 hours
so here you have a screenshots from two
out of like six entries to this
little competition for the comprehensive
list
of all the amazing solutions you can
check
our blog post and if you can wait and
you still want to see
all of our packages in action i
encourage you to visit
a shiny tools website that we set up
recently
and it contains references to the github
to to the documentation and and
live examples of all our packages so you
can test them if they
can be useful for your shiny development
okay so that's all i get thank you very
much for your attention feel free to
ping me if you have
any questions and i hope you will enjoy
the rest of the session
[Music]
cheers
you